hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra's never seen and
tonight I'm watching Top Gun oh no no no
highway to the dangerzone Tom Cruise is
either a big hit or a big miss I know I
need to see Magnolia and Rain Man today
I'm just gonna watch Top Gun I have the
limited 3d edition right here is this a
movie that needs to be in 3d I don't
know make it a lot of a lot of leather
on leather action noises here just
really fun for everyone what can I say
except you're welcome you're welcome
let's just get into this before I every
wardrobe decision I've ever made
okay
[Music]
you
uh-oh I've got some unpopular opinions
here just in my pocket here they are I
didn't love this movie you guys I
thought that it was a super generic
story I would rather see any other film
about aviation not that I know of any
The Aviator there's one nailed it I've
said this in the legend
Tamra's never seen with Doug I think his
younger stuff he's a little dopey which
I kind of find endearing because he's so
aggressively like handsome now and he
like he's almost 60s that I don't know
seeing him is like a dopey dude with not
perfect teeth and a unibrow is endearing
a little bit so I I didn't hate Tom
Cruise in this I hated Tom Cruise's
character though there was a really
great homoerotic volleyball scene which
is fun other than that though I really
could have gone my whole life without
seeing this film character that Tom
Cruise plays has some massive daddy
issues which reminded me a lot of the
Green Lantern movie because in that
movie Hal Jordan had some really intense
daddy issues his dad was a pilot oh my
god they were all pilot he like exploded
in front of him and then this he was
like you had daddy issues because his
dad was a pilot and he was really good
and then he just disappeared I don't
think he ever resolved that either in
the movie he's like somebody knows
somebody with crazy clearance knows and
they never found out did they if they
did I missed it out of sheer boredom but
he's super irresponsible in the air he's
like it's because you know my dad and
stuff and it's like we all have parent
shit dude you can't use that as an
excuse not in adulthood maybe he's a kid
you can but not as an adult's you can't
do it not to that extent where you're
endangering people's lives I don't walk
around with like insulin needles and
like prick people and say
I've got daddy issues you know like it's
not a thing so in the beginning he is in
the Air Force and he's got a whole team
around him and they're doing some drills
and and this guy with the codename
Cougars flying around and he's super
nervous I just wrote down Tom Cruise got
maverick and his partner got goose
unfair one thing I will give this film
is that it had an amazing one liner son
your ego is writing checks your body
can't cash ha ha so 80 so the whole
cougar incident where he didn't want to
Lance cuz he was nervous and so he
almost lives and he goes back out and
yeah it doesn't have any fuel to go back
out but he still does it anyways and
instead of Tom Cruise landing maverick
and goose they decide to go up and talk
to him man-to-man so they're flying next
to each other and he's like helping him
get down and he finally lands but it was
really dangerous and it's like well I
understand you want to see his face but
also you have walkie
you're not like yelling to each other so
you still could have communicated dead
by the rules but he can't because then
the dad issues so the commander is like
super super super mad at them for this
whole thing so mad that he but gives
them their greatest wishes he's like you
don't your problem is you're too good
it's like cool you got a zing and then
he's like I'm gonna send you off and
give you your wildest dreams Top Gun
yeah that's right
that's what this like I don't think you
understand how to punish people they
really went hard on that unibrow they
were like you know what yeah this what's
your worker with here mr. Cruz perfect
keep it the 80s were a time man
they were a time so they're out
celebrating Tom Cruise maverick sees
this woman he wants to beg and he he and
goose go up to her and start singing and
she's like alright you can sit and then
she is eventually like tells him to
leave her alone and so she gets up and
walks away instead of just leaving it it
back he follows her into the women's
bathroom and like is relentlessly like
come on go I'll be mama and I love it
because the next day
turns out the she's his instructor yes
that's awesome I love that but then it's
not cool it's not well done at all
because then it's like he turns it into
a sexy thing where he's like you know
holding something above her head he's
like I have information that you want
it's very much this trope of like if I
push long enough and if I'm persistent
I'll get the girl that's not a good
thing to teach anyone I know it's gonna
be like Oh humans of the Internet aren't
gonna like that I don't enjoy that but I
don't I don't think that's cute if he
was like a tan overweight or like a very
creepy guy or like he wasn't Tom Cruise
this would be a very different film it
would be in film about like this woman
being harassed but because his Tom
Cruise and because he's got a gorgeous
unibrow and she has a leather jacket and
a motorcycle
suddenly it's okay maybe best line of
any film I want some but then you get
the volleyball scene which is just a
brief breather in a otherwise terrible
film it's not terrible I just it wasn't
for me personally but the volleyball
scene it was for me also Val Kilmer yes
Iceman Iceman do you cometh
we'll be there humor for ya ladies and
gentlemen I am here to present you with
what I think is the cheesiest and most
terrible writing I've ever witnessed
Jesus Christ you think I'm reckless I'll
have you know that when I fly my crew
and my plane come first well I'm gonna
finish my sentence lieutenant my review
of your flight performance was spot-on
oh is that right that is right but I
held something back maverick something
that I couldn't say back there I see
some genius in your flying I was afraid
that everyone in the tax trailer would
see right through me and I just don't
want anyone to know that I've fallen for
you bum-bum-bum take my breath away I'm
embarrassed that I just did that no I'm
not I don't care I feel the need the
need for speed then goose dies he just
killed goose he didn't do it his jet
malfunctioned
so he doesn't do well when he goes back
into the sky cuz he's nervous and then
he decides she's gonna quit and then he
decides he's just gonna leave without
saying goodbye to the woman the heat
apparently love that has fallen for then
he doesn't quit he decides to graduate
so all of that was so pointless after
graduation they go on an actual mission
to put a really nice cap on this lovely
well told an interesting story he freaks
out of course in the moment but then he
gains confidence and saves the day I was
definitely sad to see goose go he was by
far my favorite character right after
Val Kilmer
but I didn't really get invested at all
other than that I think I might have
went into it a little negative too I
think I might have known that I wasn't
going to enjoy it and then just like
didn't enjoy even more because of that
that's something you've really got to
watch when you're watching films
especially going back to old films that
a lot of people have seen and like him
you always heard I should watch Top Gun
at some point I try really hard not to
do and I'm usually really good at going
into it with a blank slate this one I
kind of I didn't do that so that's also
probably why I'm coming out
such negative there's so much damn
sexual tension in this film there is a
lot of sexual tension in this film
especially in that volleyball FINA and
the loved it I loved it I loved young
Mew I was gonna love the volleyball
scene you will laugh when you notice the
incredible length they go through to
make Tom Cruise appear tall I didn't
even notice so that means they did a
great job and that is fascinating to me
fascinating as a 5 foot tall human I
definitely had to like stand on Apple
boxes while filming certain scenes with
certain people you'll blink and almost
miss the fact that meg Ryan is in this I
love - meg Ryan in this and I also loved
the guy that plays her husband moose I
thought that that was a great pairing -
Val Kilmer movies in a row have you
fallen in love yet depending on which
order you watch things you'll either
call val kilmer your huckleberry
or your wingman or something else oh man
thank you so much for watching next week
I'm gonna watch Howl's Moving Castle
please check it out
[Music]
[Applause]
you